toi Delphine alors moi c'est pas moi qui
aurait dû donner de l'argent c'était
plutôt l'inverse j'aurais reçu de
l'argent en fait c'était un il y a
quelques années un riche industriel d'un
âge très certain m'a vraiment proposé
très explicitement de me donner beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent pour non mais vraiment
beaucoup d'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non mais en fait donc il m'a proposé
pour pour vraiment être à ses côtés mais
on met en permanence en fait
si tu nous donnes pas de chiffres
on t'a pas demandé le nom on t'a demandé
le chiffre ah oui non mais par contre
j'ai une deuxième anecdote
[Applaudissements]
je vais te dire la vérité en plus c'est
rien c'est Mathieu il y a longtemps
le prix
non il m'a fait comprendre il m'a fait
comprendre que il allait vraiment me
mettre vraiment très très bien
c'est-à-dire
proposition
et demi
sauf que quelqu'un qui veut payer c'est
Robert Redford
si ce n'est plus et non mais c'est vrai
et donc voilà et donc il vous a proposé
beaucoup d'argent il dit quoi et donc et
donc vous avez dit quoi que je pouvais
valoir quoi 10 millions vous avez dit
quoi la question c'est est-ce que vous
êtes inestimable comme vous tous ici
que j'étais pas je ne mangeais pas de ce
par là je ne mange pas
est-ce que tu pourrais vivre avec
quelqu'un qui est assez âgé mais qui est
vraiment millionnaire ça veut dire que
jet tu es machin
ça ne me dérange pas et millionnaire et
millionnaire ça ne me dérange pas mais
moi mais moi je pourrais être dans une
toile de tente à quelqu'un qui a pas
d'argent si je l'aime et ben c'est une
bonne nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est vrai non mais c'est vrai
franchement
tu as dit qu'il y avait un autre truc
non il y avait un autre truc non par
rapport au site de rencontre parce qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure de rencontres ben
moi j'ai le truc inverse c'est-à-dire
que les périodes où j'ai été célibataire
non si j'essaie sur des sites de
rencontres où il faut mettre sa photo et
du coup vu que je pouvais pas mettre ma
photo je mettais une photo fake
d'Internet et donc du coup au bout d'un
moment je parlais bien avec le gars et
il me disait envoie-moi une photo donc
j'envoie une photo fake et dire ouais
non c'est pas possible je suis sûr que
c'est un fake et tout ça et c'est pas
que c'est moi qui était derrière donc du
coup j'ai jamais pu la vérité qui est
mieux que le fake
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est magnifique Jean-Michel et
blacklisté de tinder et moi je voulais
vérités les sites gays je suis
blacklisté aussi parce que quand on
débute si tu vois que la personne est
confiante t'envoie ta tête et tout
utiliser gros mytho il bloquait et il me
signalait et quand elle était signé les
trois fois comme un fake est bloqué et
maintenant je suis bloqué il faut que
j'ai fait il faudrait que j'appelle le
site que j'envoie une carte d'identité
va te faire donc de toute façon
voilà je suis bloqué